bonjour bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
semaine cinématographique semaine un
petit peu spécial parce que cette
semaine c'est naturellement le lancement
du festival de cannes
donc vous avez dernièrement la fiche le
nouveau j'ai remué ce qui est sorti hier
et qui a fait les montées des marches de
cannes que toute la semaine va être
marquée par des nouvelles sorties
ponctuée par les sorties de camions donc
notamment vous allez retrouver le
nouveau film aussi de pedro almodovar
douleur et gloire qui sortira uniquement
vendredi en salle
vous retrouvez aussi de nouveau film de
jean reno s'écoule blog legacy or c'est
l'histoire d'un tueur à gages qui est à
la retraite et qui va reprendre du
service pour sauver une belle qui va
entrer guinée atterrir devant sa porte
vous allez retrouver également deux
avant-premières john wick parabellum ou
donc c'est la suite des jeunes week
la grande première sera vendredi vous
retrouvez également aussi une
avant-première dimanche ça pour les plus
jeunes téléspectateurs c'est ce taudis
qui raconte la gloire d'un petit chien
qui va devenir héros de la première
guerre mondiale
et vous allez avoir aussi le dernier
film de charlize theron sédunois si tu
peux alors c'est l'histoire d'une femme
qui est destiné à de grandes destinées
pour la maison blanche américaine et qui
va engager il plume qui nettoie que
l'ancien personnes avec qui elle faisait
des cités dans ces zones rezaï voilà un
petit peu pour les grandes nouveautés de
cette semaine à l'ugc skies
[Musique]